honestly I think many many people would
be far better off not going to
University at all I think it's important
point for me to make sure I found a part
of a team founding a new College it
might make it seem like I think college
is the answer I think by and large most
if not most
very very many people can and should and
will lead higher and better and More
Beautiful lives by not going to college
and we need to remember that right we
don't want to become a place that
somehow thinks we're all just minds or
that everyone has a mind that is good at
thinking about this we have people who
would in the in the true diversity of
the human race we need people who are
doing many different kinds of things and
most of them by the way don't involve
going to college
I'm Dave Rubin and we are at the local
Studio here in Miami and I am joined by
Stephen Blackwood the co-founder and
president of Ralston College in Savannah
Georgia Stephen we're almost dressed
exactly the same it's nice to see you
good to be here thank you uh so we did
we've only done one show together in in
my many many years of interviewing
people so I want to talk about Ralston
College a place of actual learning from
what I understand and Jordan Peterson's
intimately involved in what you guys are
doing so I know this will be interesting
to my audience so first off uh give me a
one minute bio on you how you ended up
starting this place and then we'll talk
about what's going on over there
gosh well uh in some sense I'm just a
just just a firm boy who discovered you
know Big Ideas and the difference that
education can make in in made in my life
and and that I believe can make in the
lives of many the role of places in a
cult plays in a culture
so I had my own trajectory educationally
I studied uh kind of philosophy and
Classics I worked in the inner city for
a while lived abroad did a PhD in in
Atlanta at Emory University
and uh basically sort of with my with my
with the other founders of the college
sort of surveyed the landscape of higher
education which there are in which there
are many let's say chronic and systemic
problems and rather than that would be
one way of putting it well you know
let's let's maybe understand rather than
overstate but yeah let's say that the
problems are serious uh but rather than
than being uh focused on the problems we
thought well maybe we can do something
positive you know what what could we do
it's easy it's always easy to kind of
and complain about things and
frankly I think there's too much of that
in our world generally and so we thought
well let's see if we can do something
better more beautiful more wonderful
more transformative for students and uh
that was essentially the impetus so how
you got on my radar was Jordan Peterson
said to me do you know this Stephen
Blackwood guy do you know what's going
on at Ralston and
you are here actually in Miami right now
because you're doing the the biblical
series with Jordan you're about to
finish it up this afternoon uh before we
do all the Ralston stuff in education
all that can you just talk about the
biblical series and what that's been
like being with these these cast of
characters Shapiro has been there and
Prager and a whole bunch of uh of great
thinkers
well I mean this this I think this is
really interesting phenomenon frankly uh
as everyone knows Dr Peterson uh one of
his one of his first really big Works
was a series of lectures he gave on the
Book of Genesis and I think I think the
story is he just thought that you know
maybe it was possible that this this
kind of perennial text that people been
reading for you know more than 2000
years uh was there a way it might speak
to a wide audience if he just gave it
his best shot at trying to make sense of
it and I think the story was that he
just booked a theater for you know 16
nights or something and it sold out and
I think there's actually quite an
important moment in in Dr Peterson's own
um thinking through uh what his own uh
you might say what his own vocation is
and what the work of our time is and put
that I can speak for him of course but I
think the uh it's a pretty simple
formula in a way uh there are all kinds
of wonderful Treasures things figured
out in the past great books works of art
ways of understanding uh cultural uh
let's say uh cultural wisdom that it's
just there it's just there I mean it's
it's you know we're not living in a
place we're not actually the situation
is not that we're in a desert or we're
at the beginning of time and nothing's
ever been done we've got to figure out
how to do it all uh the situation is is
as if
as if everyone's hungry and you're told
there's nothing to eat there's no food
there's no it's it's just that we're in
a we're in a famine but actually you go
over here and there's you open this door
over here and
there's the biggest most beautiful Feast
ever known to man all here anything you
could imagine the most beautifully
prepared and and and and and and and
gorgeously grown produce and and so on
and so forth and we see I don't belade
with the metaphor but the point I'm
making is that in fact we've got this
this tree you could change this to think
we have no we have no Beauty and say
well actually look at all these amazing
things so the point is a simple one it
is that I think the Exodus seminar has
been born of a very simple and insight
and that is that these these works that
human beings have found transformatively
insightful to make sense of their own
lives for you know two thousand three
thousand years that they can still speak
today and rather than than
um simply tell people what they're about
uh what happens if we just have a
conversation about it does that come
alive in a way that it then comes alive
for us and my experience in this last uh
week and a half that we've been a week
or so that we've been here is that if
you is that this conversation which I
would say has very low to no levels of
ego which is sincerely just trying to
figure out this amazing text and see
what we can understand about it has been
a really uh beautiful and memorable
experience and and it's a very
interesting thing to note Dave that
there appears to be a wide audience of
people who are hungry for that kind of
non-instrumental not reductively
political richly
expansive deep content that says
something to them about what the nature
of human life is to bring that metaphor
into everything that's going on in the
world today I mean it sort of feels to
me like we've been wandering in the
desert with a lot of lies a lot of
untruths half-truths a lot of confusion
but there does seem to be a promised
land on the other side of that where
people are are seriously talking about
how to rebuild things how to get us to
that that land where there is goodness
and all those things what what's your
role specifically at the table because
everyone sort of has a little bit of
their own expertise right yeah I think
that's that's right my background is
really is in uh philosophy and theology
so I'm a kind of history of ideas what
are the fundamental questions kind of
person but I would say in this seminar
I've found myself turning again and
again to ask the kind of almost personal
question you know what does it say to me
right now and
I suppose I think that's in a way the
the big question I'm also aware that the
other on the daily wire plus there's
going to be a lot of a lot of people
listening to this not simply for let's
say I don't know academic or scholarly
reasons they're trying to figure out
their lives she says I'm trying to
figure out mine and we all are and so I
think my uh what I've tried to do at
least is trying to approach things from
that angle all right so let's bring that
conversation this wandering in the
desert we all seem to be doing to why
you would start a co-found a school I
mean a lot of it is because the
information is all nonsensical right
everyone everyone in in the world seems
to be wandering in that desert
academically and there aren't many
promised lands is that a well I think
that's up nicely for you or what I think
I think it's I think it's very important
I I think actually Exodus does give us
really fundamental language of the
landscape of our own experience right
we're all in some sense are living in
states of of of longing or do you might
say the desert a place where we're we're
trying to find our way we're confused
we're battering around we're lonely
we're alienated whatever we got our our
personal issues and so on and then the
question is well how do you how do you
how do you make sense out of that and
that way I think is in a way with the
book of Exodus is itself at least taken
historically by people's of various
phase to be a kind of Revelation about
uh how to how one can move from that
state
and it doesn't come down just to
ourselves by the way either but relative
to education and the founding of Ross in
college I think what I'd say is it's a
couple things the first is you know at a
big sort of systemic cultural level I
think we've got to be really honest with
ourselves and say right now the West
generally so the United States and any
other country I know should by and large
the countries of North America and
Europe principally uh we do not now have
the mechanisms of transmission for our
own culture right uh so let's take uh
you know the Constitution the United
States or you know the forms of building
things that are beautiful or the forms
of the forms of ritual that have Defined
Life you know in in profound ways these
have been eroded or degraded or
abandoned or forgotten and you know one
cannot overstate what a problem that is
you can't you cannot have a culture
without mechanisms of transmission of
that culture right it's like imagine if
you you know your your your French or
German or whatever if you stop speaking
that language right it's gone within a
generation and so so the the what all a
culture really is is a kind of the late
philosopher uh sir sir Roger scrutin put
it beautifully he said in a way a
culture is just the things we have loved
but you know
how does the only way something that we
have loved gets transmitted is by
teaching someone else to love it too and
right now instead of of a kind of not
slavish uh uh obedience but you know
humble openness and and respect to the
past is is it has been replaced in many
respects with ignorance or antagonism or
this was just a history of Oppression or
I think well
this is a profoundly
Insidious way of regarding all of the
things that human beings up until now
could teach us if we would just listen
so do I make that General point about
the systemic thing because I want to I
want to make be very clear that this is
not kind of window dressing or well we
could kind of have this or have it that
way I'm talking about the most
fundamental reality of the world in
which we live and and the Very
conditions of human flourishing as
they've been understood in in the United
States and in the west I would say those
are being forgot have been or are
forgotten in fundamental ways the next
thing I would say is well you can you
can have this sort of analysis that you
know there are problems in this field or
this field or that domain or in this
industry or whatever but you know
even a good grasp on the problems like a
good kind of critical understanding that
only takes you so far because you can't
build out of a negative Vision you can't
build it of criticism so I I often give
the example I make no bones about the
fact that I don't like brutalist
architecture I think it's ugly I think
it's sold to me it's Soul destroying I
think it's alienating it has no way in
to understand yourself it's kind of
demeaning rather than elevating but you
know not liking brutalist architecture
allows you to build exactly zero
buildings that are different right you
got to say well you know I'm for you
know a certain vision of proportion and
Symmetry and so on so you know what
we're trying to do is something positive
and that positive I want to just say one
third the third point I would make is is
you can talk about systems you can talk
about positive vision and everything but
you know what at the end of the day this
comes down to individuals and you know
the way you transmit a culture is is by
by giving something beautiful a form of
of deeper and richer self-understanding
to an individual and that you might say
is meant to be what the heart or the
core activity of Ralston college is
about about giving something
transformative in a in a free and
beautiful non-instrumental non-corsive
way to help people contend with the most
fundamental human questions
are you surprised that more schools
aren't doing this or abjected their duty
to do this or
just come or or is it obvious because it
was the end of all of what we now call
woke that these ideas got so into all of
the schools that it's pretty obvious
they were all going to end up this way
and that you'd have to start a school
like this well I think it's it's it you
know I just say very quickly two things
the first is that you know that this is
a multi-factorial problem you know
there's a long history and you can you
can talk about the the the
vocationalization of the University that
is partly to do with trying to to
educate a much wider swath of of of of
our of our country and culture and
that's a that's a that's a noble
Instinct but it's also kind of shifted
the university towards more I don't know
more marketing and less art history or
something like that and and so that's
that's a question and then and then
you've got the whole student loan crisis
you know the way the federal the federal
government is radically distorting these
things and you know not only leading to
inflation and things like that but but
essentially there's no normal Market
corrective on a poor product because the
federal governments would just give
anyone anything they want just to study
at University it's a disaster it's right
you have way too many people go going to
get degrees that are often not worth the
paper they're printed on or not finished
or whatever you should look at the
completion rates it's unbelievable
nationally and then you know you've got
how bad are you I can't give you it I
don't want to do it misspeak but there
are many there are many places in which
Dropout rates are are are well over 50 I
I think I'm not not speaking to say well
over 50 or incompletion rates and so
that's to say people not finishing the
degree they started and so but they're
still they're still a loan for the money
that they spend on the time that they
don't get decreased it's just ironically
with some of the stuff they're learning
it's probably not the worst thing well
you're not finishing but uh honestly I
think many many people would be far
better off not going to University at
all I think it's important point for me
to make sure I found a part of a team
founding a new College it might make it
seem like I think college is the answer
I think by and large most if not most
very very many people can and should and
will lead higher and better and More
Beautiful lives by not going to college
and we need to remember that right we
don't want to become a place that
somehow thinks we're all just minds or
that everyone has a mind that is good at
thinking about this we have people who
are in the in the true diversity of the
human race we need people who are doing
many different kinds of things and most
of them by the way don't involve going
to college but all that is to say that
in uh in in in in in what we're doing
we're seeking to be grounded
fundamentally in a positive vision and
and relative to the to the to you this
historic Arc of what's gone wrong in
higher education you can analyze this
from any number of different ways
there's the the woke and the ideology
and the politicization of Education it's
a huge problem
um and whether whether it is inevitable
I think actually yes it is I think there
is there is no there is no continuity
without without sort of birth and
rebirth and you can look at any industry
anytime anywhere and I think in the
higher education United States I mean
you really want to really get into it
these problems are not new I mean you
can go back to you know it's kind of an
ER text for many you know small C
conservatives as William F Buckley's God
man of Yale it's written in 1950 or 51
or 52 it's or very early 50s that's 70
years ago you can look at the most
famous book in this as regarded as Alan
Bloom's closing of the American mind
written in 1985 I mean that's a long
time ago and he said well what have we
done in this time and I think broadly
speaking people thought well we can kind
of Reform from within and I think we
should never give up on a great
institution it would be nihilism to give
up on something beauty that has been
meaningful and could still be meaningful
but at the same time I think we have to
admit that that strategy has been an
abysmal failure because during the time
in which we've been supposed supposedly
trying to do things internally I would
say the situation with the universities
has got far worse in that time than
better and so the point is is finally to
say that
you know
I think the current situation is like
the one I gave with the example of
hunger because you know let me just say
ask you whether you would agree with
this
because you speak to a lot of people you
have a good sense of you know the pulse
of of of a kind of a whole generation of
of people of and and multiple
Generations
I would put it to you that
know that the average
15 to 25 year old
when there are 30 year old what do you
want to say when they're trying to make
sense of life and they're like oh gosh
you know dealing with uh you know cancer
or death or suffering or depression or
my addiction or whatever I'm not trying
to make sense of my life in the deepest
way like the thing that matters the most
to all of us is like can we live a life
that we regard as worth living right
there is no more important question for
human beings than that I would put it to
you that the first that at the top of
the list of the places that they would
look is not the university no I mean and
what that and what that means is that
the place that should be one of the most
obvious places you turn the repository
of all human learning and and the
humanities which are nothing but the
record of what other human beings have
thought about their lives in the past
which is one of the key sources to try
and understand our lives the point I'm
making is that the industry broadly
speaking higher education has taken such
a wrong turn that the thing it should be
most known for people don't even turn to
it for it'd be like the last place you
turned to fill up your car was a gas
station because they no longer had any
gas it almost seems like it's the
complete reverse actually yes the 180
it's not that it's just slightly missing
or they veered off slightly they
actually give you none of those tools
they teach you a whole other set of
things that have very little to do with
in many places sadly I think that is
true yeah you may end up worse off
intellectually spirit actually morally
by having your mind corrupted by a
certain kind of
very downward looking cynical nihilism
that really and I don't think I can say
this strong enough because I'm not I'm
not a political or instrumental thinker
I think we know that there are ideas
that are really toxic for your soul and
they lead to bad places psychologically
relationally intellectually and
that's a bad place to be so when a
student comes to Ralston and you guys
have a grad program right now right and
this is where you just went to Greece
with the whole how many how many kids
did you go with our first class we
opened a mission this year our first
program is a is a one-year intensive
Masters in the humanities so it's kind
of like an intensive boot camp going
through the history of of the West it
started with two full months of
intensive study in Greece of Greek so it
was kind of boot camp in language
learning meets The Grand Tour it was
amazing uh uh full two months we started
in in Athens then a month in Samos the
island of Samos a trip to Constantinople
Istanbul and then uh and then the last
three weeks in partnership with the uh
Harvard uh Center uh for Hellenic
studies in naflio and the peloponnese so
yes we had a really intensive uh on the
ground encounter in the place in which
the ideas and ideals the you might say
originated in the West in the language
in which they origin it's no mistake
that you know philosophy theology
astronomy biology these are all Greek
words right so it's not it's not just a
kind of historical that's kind of
interesting it's like no these are the
categories of thought you know
categories of you know what does it mean
to be free what does it mean to be
autonomous there's a there's another
Greek word self-ruling that's where it
starts and so there's a real sense in
which Greece and the language of Greek
has always been kind of like a source
like a like a well that perennially
enables us if we attend to it just as
many other things history of religion
and other I'm not saying it's all about
Greece all the time but it's a core
aspect of uh Western culture since uh
its earliest days in the 5th Century BC
I did see the movie 300 and I'm pretty
sure that's why they were always taken
out Athens right well they were pretty
pissed that these people who had ideas
and were doing good things and spreading
freedom I mean I'm half kidning actually
but not fully no I don't I think I think
if if the battle if the war against the
battle against the Persians have gone
differently the uh the various famous
battles the Greeks and no business
winning right it's like you know these
massive forces of the Empire descending
on there's a little little group of of
kind of band of citizens who just said
Give Me Freedom or give me death if that
if they had not won those battles well
there would have been I think we can say
confidently there would have been no
Western culture the ideas on ideas of
Greece would not have made it out into a
wider a wider sphere that wouldn't have
been the you might say the the seeds
that laid the the the groundwork for the
whole Roman Empire uh they were the
seeds that transformed the uh the
Christian Revelation there were the
seeds in some respects they were the
ideas through which frankly all of the
the religions of the book Christianity
Judaism and Islam at certain points in
history we've all been reading their
books their holy books the by their
Bibles through the lens of Greek
philosophy and the categories of thought
we were just talking about so point of
making is that you cannot really
overstate how influential that moment is
because it is kind of the in a
significant way it is if not the one of
the sources from which the whole you
might say trunk and tree of what we now
call Western culture grows so you bring
these students there and you were
telling me the other night a little bit
about the rigorous process to just get
in the program in the first place but so
they go there they learn about the
humanities they get this the keys to
this great knowledge
um are most of them thinking about what
they're going to do after because one of
the best questions I get on this show
all the time when we do q and A's I get
from parents who are like first off
they're very leery of sending their kids
to college in the first place then the
second question is where do I send them
and the third thing is is anything that
they're going to learn they're going to
equip them to be out in the real world
if you're teaching kids all about the
humanities it's wonderful in terms of a
full life but are they thinking about
what they want to do after or is it
almost not that important yet in some
regards well I think
yeah I think this raises a really
interesting question Dave because
I think we have to think really honestly
about what is useful frankly and I would
begin my starting position would be
what matters the most to a human being
has got to be at some level what they
regard as most important and that's
that's what enables them to have that
perhaps most useful and I I really would
put it as a fundamental contention that
that there is nothing that matters more
to human beings where self-conscious
creatures we don't just live as automata
like we think about ourselves we value
things we we feel bad when we do things
that we think we shouldn't have done we
have hopes and dreams we we love we love
beauty we we We Gather in community
what I would say is there is nothing
more important than giving a human being
the tools for them to regard their own
life is Meaningful and
that doesn't come down to Simply
material things I mean you can have all
the material wealth and success in the
world and be be
feel like you are you are poor inside
that you you you can not have the
relationships that no gets the death bed
saying oh gosh I wish I just made a
little more money I mean they get the
death bed saying you know they're still
thinking about things like why did I
never reconcile with my brother and and
how could I have done so and and so I
really want to explode this idea that
that the humanities are somehow and I'm
not saying you're suggested yes but as
if they're somehow this this share thing
oh you know we imagine an English accent
or something like you know we're in a
cocktail party talking about something
that no one gives a damn about no I'm
talking about the fundamental questions
truth justice love beauty forgiveness
how do these things work what are they
and that's the Bedrock and so I'd say
that but then it also says something
more practical towards your question
which is
it's easy to think that the best way to
do something practical is practical and
in fact this is a really interesting
thing about the humanities if you
subordinate them to a practical
instrumental outcome like I said I'm
going to read Shakespeare because they
help me to teach marketing and help me
to learn how to sell razors or something
it's going to fall through your your
your hands like like Sam like you're not
gonna have anything left because you
never get anything out of damn
Shakespeare if you read them that way
whereas if you really attend to this
amazing you know uh understanding of The
Human Condition you really get into that
well you know that may make you quite
powerful when you start thinking about
what motivates people how do we speak to
people and I'm not saying it's going to
help you sell a million razors but very
well may and so the point I'm making is
that if you don't subordinate it
practically it becomes unbelievably
powerful I mean let's let's let's just
be honest about the fact that that the
kind of education I'm talking about is
in fact the education that has basically
defined
you know Statesmen politicians uh uh the
the uh the movers and shakers and doers
uh in many respects of of our whole of
our whole history so this is it's
actually a very recent idea and I think
it's
it's profoundly mistaken to think that
the way in which you can do something
important even in the real world is
you've got to start by understanding
that world fundamentally right well
that's why it's so interesting to me
that well I guess it's interesting but
obvious at the same time that Jordan is
involved with you guys because the tools
that he's always talking about for
someone to take their life seriously
well if you study the humanities
honestly and really get an assessment of
history and everything else and then you
have a little of the history and the
knowledge before you and then you start
doing those things yourself then I think
to your point in some ways that is the
tool set that you need regardless of
what you studied specifically yeah I
think that's right for a vocation I
think that's completely right and I
think when you look at I mean our
students are certainly they came from
you know from Tech and from teaching
from the art World from from from from
from a range of both you might say
pretty hardcore practical to you know
education and so on and I think that
their their careers are likely to be as
diverse as that but as in just even to
speak as an employer and I know that
that you know as you are you you can't
you can't just take it for granted that
you know someone can write a sentence in
our current day and age right and but
that's speaking of someone who who hires
people it's actually very important that
you'll be able to you know convey not
only something grammatical and not
riddled with mistakes but maybe you have
a certain tone imagine how imagine how
imagine how valuable that is if in your
life you're able
to be a kind of Master of how you
present what you say so it can be
maximally well taken on by the person
you're saying to that's about the most
useful thing you could have particularly
in a so-called knowledge economy we're
living in now so so I don't want to
undersell the really practical uh uh
side of a rigorous Humanities education
but you don't get that if you don't
approach it with serious rigor in the
first place just a couple more we can do
somewhat briefly uh I assume you're
getting probably calls every single day
from professors who are like I cannot
take this anymore hire me please I mean
is that is that part of what your job
now is certainly and we're we're really
looking forward to continuing to add to
our team as we expand there is a lot of
dissatisfaction out there
um
uh we've had of course we've had
hundreds and hundreds of CVS over the
over the the months in the last few
years and that that I think is
fundamentally it's really interesting to
ask why that is and I I think it's
because
you know there's these people that they
actually dedicated their lives because
they said you know I want to I want to I
want to be part of this sort of
beautiful transmission and opening up
the minds of the young to things that
will help them and and often they find
themselves in positions in which they're
they don't feel they can speak their
mind they're they're they're they're
they're ostracized by their colleagues
or fearful of speaking openly
um where they're they're under pressure
to politicize their own classrooms and
it's just a sort of sorry sorry position
to be in where you're not able to
really devote yourself to to the to the
high order things that inspired your own
vocation and and uh we hope that not
only do we look forward to hiring many
of those people but we also hope that in
some even small and maybe not so small
way that that what we're doing what
other new institutions are doing may
play some role in recollecting these
other institutions back to what they're
all about how hard is it building new
institutions I mean I know a little
something about building new things on
the tech side it's tough and you will
get pushed back in every possible way
you can think of and a whole bunch that
you cannot think of but I still do it I
think it's very hard is what I think I'm
not going to sit here and pretend it's
been been easy of course we've been very
fortunate to to to attract a a network
of support and and friendship and and
people who are behind us but that took
years to build and
I think it's worth saying that
that I think is also a symptom of
something we've gone very uh very badly
awry in our country I mean in the 19th
century there were I don't know there's
something like a dozen 25 if you look at
the numbers it's they were starting new
colleges and Universities at a real clip
every few months there was another one
they're the ones we have now by the way
the minute most of them were started the
19th century and and you've got to ask
yourself you know what has gone wrong
when on the one on some of these really
core issues of what we are as a culture
we've lost the dynamism to recreate and
reinvent there's a kind of of surrender
kind of capitulation to like well
what can we do and it's kind of like
you're on the Titanic man and you're
saying well I guess it's just go down I
mean you know I mean if you see what I'm
saying it's it's I think we I think we
this we've we need to be able to recover
to kind of like instead of like
remembering yourself like you know
you're you're sort of in lethargy or
depression or whatever and you remember
you come alive again I think that's what
we need as a culture and I don't think
you can do that if you have pessimism
and grumbling and why would you do that
or I've often heard oh you could never
do that and I think you know what
yes we can yeah
yes we can there was a politician who
probably isn't on board all the ideas
that that you're teaching over there
that used to end with last week uh yes
we can so that might not be the perfect
ending here so instead tell the good
people where they can go if they want to
find out more and we'll put some links
down below yeah well we'd love to have
uh love to have your listeners check out
our website at
www.rolston
r-a-l-s-t-o-n-a-c uh sign up for our
newsletter we have online lectures and
podcasts and various other various other
things what because what we're what we
had our highest hope here Dave is is not
that this is just a place for however
many students we grow to have over time
but that it it can also be a kind of
kind of Fellowship for anyone who seeks
the truth with courage and we would love
to have anyone who's listening uh join
us in that now that I softened you up
you can go talk Bible with Jordan
Peterson all right thanks for having me
you get it if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about Academia check out our Academia
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell